unune fois bientôt.
E Enrico Ciccone, député
dede Marquette et porte-parole
dudu PLQ en matière de sports,
dede loisirs et de saines
hahabitudes de vie.
- - Bonsoir Monsieur Cicognini.
- - Bonsoir Monsieur Roy.
- - Je disais que Kelly Brazier
esest un champion et que
auaujourd'hui qu'un champion ne
sosoit plus gêné de demander de
lalaisser ça le gros changement?
- - C'est extraordinaire c'est
dodommage pour Carrie et sa
fafamille mais c'est
exextraordinaire d'avoir une ide
dudu peuple ici à Montréal qui t
cacapable de dire oui faut j'ai
bebesoin d'aide je veux prendre
unune pause, aidez-moi s'il vous
plplaît. C'est extraordinaire. n
sasait que les problèmes de sané
mementale son encore tabou. Nos
niniveaux soient au niveau de la
nanational c'est encore plus
didifficile parce qu'on a toujos
cecette pression. On porte la
prpression d'un logo emploi de a
prpression d'une marque la
prpression des partisans qui
veveulent devoir gagner.
AlAlors est capable verbaliser t
didit je ne suis plus capable
exextraordinaire . D'un montant
c'c'est impossible de le dire.
- - Effectivement ça change mais
cece à votre époque est-ce que
vovous auriez pu le faire?
- - Le programme est arrivé dans
l'l'allée nationale en 1993, j'y
ététais. Le programme était là.n
paparlait plus de toxicomanie de
prproblème d'alcool de dépendane
auau jeu également. Des problèms
fafamiliaux aussi. Et ce prograe
a a été mis en place par
l'l'association des joueurs pare
quque si le joueur volontairemet
enentrait dans ce programme, il
n'n'était pas suspendu et contia
d'd'être payé, ça fait en sorte
ququ'il pourrait contrevenir avc
dedes produits illicites. S'il
ététait prêt il était suspendu.
SoSouvent on offrait que le jour
enentre lui-même dans ce
prprogramme.
- - J'entendais les gens dire
auaujourd'hui que les réseaux
sosociaux c'est un des facteurs
pepeut-être. D'abord on entre ds
unun territoire inconnu on ne st
papas ce qui arrive à acquérir
prpresse dans sa tête. Mais ce
ququ'on sait c'est que
l'l'environnement n'est pas le
mmême que quand vous vous jouie.
OuOui il y avait la pression. Vs
avavez pris par Montréal, mais à
leles réseaux sociaux décuplent
cecette pression.
- - Effectivement déjà Hestia
MoMontréal sa ya beaucoup de
prpression. À l'époque on jouait
avavec de quotidiens pages qui
vevenaient nous poser la questi.
NaNavel la pression des soit 82
sosoit par année. Aujourd'hui
c'esest à chaque minute à chaque
seseconde. Même si le joueur dit
jeje ne m'occupe pas de ça je ls
papas les rôles sociaux, il y a
totoujours quelqu'un qui vient n
paparler. Est-ce qu'il est
didifficile et on a vu, ce n'est
papas rien on a eu des actes de
hahaut niveau qui ont flashé pae
quque justement ils sont plus
cacapables de voir ce qui se pae
avavec les réseaux sociaux. Queu
sosois gros grand effort tu fais
1010 millions par année nous
sosommes tous des êtres humainst
àà un moment donné un point de
rurupture.
- - Peut-être qu'on apprendra qà
unune certaine époque de grands
chchampions comme Patrick Roy,
écécrit un livre de ces moments
didifficiles. Être gardien de bt
onon arrête pas de répéter c'est
unun joueur central que sans lui
totous écroulaient. On ne peut s
avavoir plus de pression que ça?
- - Marc Bergevin devrait être
sesensible à ce point je la come
jojoueurs comme entraîneur. Quad
tutu vois ce genre de choses
ararriver ça fais mal. Ça m'a
raramené moi aussi au moment oùl
avavait un point de rupture où
j'j'avais de la difficulté, où e
paparle à ma conjointe en disant
jeje ne suis plus capable je n'i
plplus la force de le faire. Noe
cocorps est affaibli et meurtrin
mmême temps ne pouvait pas le dt
papas ce qu'on lui dit il y a
totoujours quelqu'un qui va nous
rérépéter sans cesse. En ce cas,
paparce que moi je fais plus que
toton salaire.
- - Vous avez raison de le
sosouligner mais il y a quand me
unune partie de vrai. S'il est
papayé plus cher c'est parce que
sasa recevabilité, son rôle est
imimportant.
- - Effectivement important mais
çaça ne lui enlève pas le fait e
KeKelly Brazier un être humain i
vivit avec ses forces et
fafaiblesses. Nous sommes tous s
êêtres humains nous vivons